moi je pense que les femmes brésiliennes
ont sans doute honte de dire ça de leur
président je pense que les brésiliens
qui sont un grand peuple ont un peu
honte de voir ces comportements et ils
attendent quand on est président qu'on
se comporte bien à l'égard des autres et
comme j'ai beaucoup d'amitié de respect
pour le peuple brésilien
j'espère très rapidement qu'ils auront
un président qui se comporte à la
hauteur
[Musique]
furent les propos de monsieur molson
arrow de ses ministres je serai pas
tellement de commentaires
vous savez moi je respecte chaque
dirigeant élu par son pays parce que je
respecte tous les peuples et pays
je pense c'est très important maintenant
je suis obligé de constater que et sans
doute eu trois malentendu avec le
président bolle sonar où j'ai vu une
première fois il m'a dit la main sur le
coeur je vais tout faire pour l'art
force reforestation et l'engagement des
accords de paris pour pouvoir signer le
mercosur
quinze jours après il faisait le
contraire en limogeant des scientifiques
est bon de dire qu'il m'a pas dit la
vérité
quelques semaines après il a eu un
rendez vous urgent c'est le coiffeur
quand il devait recevoir le ministre des
affaires étrangères et puis il se trouve
qu hier il a considéré que c'est une
bonne idée que son ministre ça n'arrive
jamais en france qu'un ministre de la
république insultes quelques dirigeants
que ce soit profère des insultes à mon
endroit et lui qu'il tienne des propos
extraordinairement et respectueux à
l'égard de mon épouse
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire c'est
triste c'est triste mais c'est triste
d'abord pour lui et pour les brésiliens
et donc moi je pense que les femmes
brésiliennes ont sans doute honte de
dire ça de leur président je pense que
les brésiliens qui sont un grand peuple
ont un peu honte de voir ces
comportements et ils attendent quand on
est président qu'on se comporte bien à
l'égard des autres et comme j'ai
beaucoup d'amitié de respect pour le
peuple brésilien
j'espère très rapidement qu'ils auront
un président qu'est-ce qu'on porte à la
hauteur